bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat mercredi la
commission d' enquête sur l'efficacité
de la lutte antidopage a auditionné
pierre berbizier
l'ancien entraîneur de l'équipe de
france de rugby ainsi que l'ancien
médecin de cette équipe
marc bichon cette audition intervient
après les propos tenus le 30 mai par
l'ancien pilier de cette équipe de
france et demi finaliste de la coupe du
monde de rugby
95 laurent bénézech il avait alors
déclaré devant cette même commission
denquête être convaincu d'avoir été
traité à son insu à la cortisone mettant
ainsi directement en cause la
responsabilité de l'ancien entraîneur de
l'équipe de france ainsi que celle de
l'ancien médecin de cette équipe
marc bichon mais tout de suite direction
la salle clemenceau pour voir ou revoir
cette audition très bonne après midi à
tous sur notre chaîne ce colloque si on
replace merci monsieur xavier bonjour
docteur michon bonjour bonjour nous
sommes très heureux de vous accueillir
on l'avait souhaité nous devons donner
suite à votre demande nous sommes dans
le cadre d'une commission denquête et je
me dois de vous rappeler un certain
nombre d'obligations qui sont les votes
comme elles sont les nôtres parce que
cette commission d' enquête
vous allez nous apporter un éclairage
sur votre point de vue concernant le
dopage
nous sommes obligés avec mes collègues
de vous dire non pas de vous rappeler de
vous dire que cette audition et et
public et que vous avez l'obligation de
dire la vérité toute la vérité
chacun peut avoir sa version de la
vérité mais tout le monde doit nous dire
la vérité vous comme les autres et j'ai
fait à chacune de vos nombreuses
auditions mais on travaille depuis trois
mois et demi maintenant le même discours
en vous demandant l'un après l'autre de
bien vouloir prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité de l'est la main
droite et jure ce derby est tout d'abord
je le jure a jugé en parle excusez moi
c'est que vous répétiez le n'est pas
habituée ces termes je radote parfois
mais la docteure bichon je le jure merci
la tradition dans notre commission
denquête avec l'accord de l'ensemble des
membres
c'est de pouvoir donner la possibilité à
celles et ceux qui ont souhaité parler
de disposer d'environ un quart d'heure
certes je suis originaire de la capitale
de l'horlogerie française et européenne
un peu moins aujourd'hui qu'il ya
quelques années encore mais bon on
essaiera tenir à peu près les délais
mais vous avez en gros un quart d'heure
pour vous exprimer sur le sujet par un
quart d'heure chacun l'un d'entre vous
les deux
prendrait le temps nécessaire dans le
cadre d'un quart d'heure pour nous
donner votre version des choses et nous
aurons la possibilité de vous poser
quelques questions ensuite si vous le
voulez bien je devais normalement
demandé au public
le public est souvent remplacé par un
certain nombre de membres de la presse
donc ça s'applique aussi à eux on ne
doit pas manifester ni positivement ni
négativement en fonction de ce que l'on
entend on doit écouter
donc merci de bien vouloir vous résoudre
pour une fois écouté ses propos
liminaires et en tenue je vous laisse le
soin de parler qui commence aussi
berbizier dr guijon dr michaud voilà les
temps étant le plus jeune c'est moi qui
vais commencer
voilà donc tout d'abord nous vous
remercions pierre et moi d'avoir accepté
de nous entend dans le cadre de cette
commission qui est mail entendu sur le
rapport sur l'efficacité de la lutte
antidopage et dont nous avons bien
conscience de ce pourquoi nous sommes là
et vous savez également que nous y
sommes parce que des propos ont été
tenus sur nos propres personnes et en
particulier sur la mienne en touchant un
petit peu mots mon intégrité personnelle
et mon intégrité médical ce qui est
quand même un petit peu plus grave et
donc si vous permettez je vais en très
brève introduction vous dire qui nous
sommes
pierre est beaucoup plus connu que moi
et moi je vais vous dire faire un petit
geste de de ma vie et de ma vie dans le
monde du sport
donc je m'appelle marc bichon je suis né
le 27 avril 1950 donc je suis plus tout
à fait très jeune à carmaux dans le tarn
un pays riche en rugby y est érigé en
matière politique comme certains d'entre
vous le savent
j'ai prêté serment une première fois le
serment d'hippocrate en novembre 1978 et
j'ai commencé ma carrière le 19 avril
1979 au ministère de la jeunesse et des
sports
en tant que médecins contractuels et
médecin chef du centre d'entraînement en
altitude de font romeu qui s'appelait à
l'époque lycée climatique et sportives
et fond et donc j'ai fait pendant de
1979 à 1986 j'ai été le médecin de ce
centre d'entraînement en altitude ce qui
m'a valu eu l'occasion de parler
beaucoup dans le monde de l'an de ce
qu'est d'entraînement en altitude et au
delà de ça de rencontrer de grandes
équipes et de s'occuper personnellement
de la préparation en altitude qui de
france football en 1982 à 1984 et en
1986 en janvier 86 j'ai été affecté au
creps de toulouse dont j'ai créé le
service médical et j'ai crée également
une un département d'évaluation
recherche
c'était la grande époque de l'évaluation
au ministère des sports et nous étions
missionné j'étais personnellement
missionné pour la fédération française
de rugby pour la fédération française
d'athlétisme pour la fédération des
sports de glace et j'en passe pour les
aider à développer leurs programmes de
développement et l'évaluation
au travers de cette carrière je suis
resté médecin chef du creps de toulouse
jusqu'en 2004 et pendant toute cette
période j'ai été un acteur modeste
certes de la lutte antidopage
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur
l'information de nos jeunes sportifs et
sur la formation de nos jeunes sportifs
vis-à-vis des problèmes du dopage car
c'était notre devoir et notre mission et
dans le même temps j'ai été pour la
deuxième fois j'ai prêté serment puisque
j'étais médecin préleveur est donc
devant le tribunal de grande instance de
toulouse je suis allé prêter serment
donc j'avais prêté deux fois serment et
la troisième fois aujourd'hui devant
vous
c'est un honneur pour moi voilà donc
vous dire que au travers de cette
carrière bien sûr les problèmes du
dopage ont toujours été en filigrane
derrière nous et bon c'est quelque chose
dont j'avais fait mon mon combat entre
guillemets je ne dis pas que je ne fais
pas aujourd'hui mais je suis un petit
peu loin du sport de très haut niveau
mais j'ai fait mon combat de cette lutte
antidopage et j'ai fait mon combat
surtout de la formation et de
l'information de nos jeunes sportifs
vis-à-vis de toute cette problématique
dans toutes ces années les choses ont
évolué elles ont évolué grandement c'est
à dire qu'au début
entre guillemets nos propos étaient des
propos entre un petit peu de curé je
dirais fais pas ci fais pas ça voilà la
liste ça et puis petit à petit on est
allé maintenant on est plus dans la
lutte contre les conduites addictives et
c'est vrai que dans ces centres
d'entraînement n'a plus de problème de
type à l'équipe vis-à-vis de la
cigarette vis-à-vis de du cannabis est
un petit peu de l'alcool mais bien
entendu on continue à expliquer à nos
jeunes sportifs qui sont des sportifs de
compétition
quels sont leurs droits et devoirs
comment ils doivent se comporter lors
d'un contrôle antidopage
voilà donc ça ça a été tout eu toute ma
vie ça l'est encore aujourd'hui mais ça
a été toute ma vie de mes 25 ans de
ministère de la jeunesse et des sports
et à l'époque nous nous sommes
rencontrés avec pierre berbizier ou à
l'époque il m'avait gentiment offert de
l'accompagner au niveau de l'équipe de
france de rugby
j'étais appartenant au ministère des
sports ce qui fait que je dirais
modestement que les propos qui ont été
tenus l'autre jour me me blesse et et me
touche profondément parce que
effectivement j'étais à 100 milles eu
lieu fort mille lieux de ce qui a été
dit l'autre jour c'est ce que je voulais
dire en préambule je vais demander à
pierre de continuer merci pour
ses premiers mots supervision mais pour
ma part je vois que j'aime qu'on ne
longue route à part dont j'ai encore un
peu de route à faire puisque par rapport
à mort ce n'est que la première fois que
je prête serment
il me reste deux ans encore pour boucler
la boucle donc un petit peu de route
pour moi juste rectifier par rapport la
présentation je vois un ancien joueur de
rugby professionnel
j'ai jamais été joueur de rugby
professionnel
juste pour préciser notamment l'époque
qui dans lesquelles j'ai été cité même
entraîneur je n'étais pas entraîneur
professionnel dont je suis d'une
génération
je n'ai pas connu le professionnalisme
en tant que tel comme joueur ou
entraîneur de l'équipe de france dans
l'épisode qui qui me concerne
aujourd'hui donc on on travaillait à
l'époque et pour finir de me présenter
donc moi j'ai commencé j'ai commencé
comme comme prof de gym donc j'ai
éduquer les enfants j'ai entraîné des
adolescents légers entraînaient ensuite
des adultes donc aujourd'hui me
retrouver devant vous je voulais d'abord
vous remercier
puisqu'un autre demande c'était le seul
moyen pour pour s'exprimer devant des
faits complètement surréaliste en ce qui
me concerne quand j'ai entendu ces
propos je dois vous avouer que je suis
un bon mais c'est comme ça et je vous
remercie de nous recevoir pour au moins
nous exprimer parce qu'on n'avait pas
d'autres cadres dans la mesure où le
cadre juridique de la diffamation ne
peut pas être utilisés aujourd'hui
donc merci beaucoup de nous recevoir de
pouvoir nous exprimer sur le sur le
dossier dans la mesure où comme marc et
si j'ai fait appel à marc dans cette
période pour m'aider m'aider pour
encadrer l'équipe de france c'était
d'abord par rapport à son expérience de
médecin
c'était deux de haut niveau c'était
aussi par rapport à ces problèmes là
sachant qu'on avait
des moyens beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
limité on s'occupait de la préparation
physique christophe mombet lui
s'occupait vidéo statistiques qui était
notre entraîneur donc on n'avait pas ça
médical très très très fournie que ce
soit pour la préparation physique et ces
problèmes là dans notre organisation du
travail va essayer de les traiter dans
une organisation du travail parce que je
crois que le haut niveau c'est beaucoup
de travail et par rapport à ces
problèmes là il ya certains principes de
ma formation de prof de gym dans
d'éducateurs et d'entraîneurs qui qui
m'ont convaincu qu effectivement lancée
par l'organisation du travail et un
certain travail qu'on peut arriver et
confirmés au niveau et peut-être lutter
contre contre le problème sur lequel on
va on va parler aujourd'hui
ç'a toujours été mes principes ç'a
toujours été ma conviction et je dois
vous avouer que mes principes
aujourd'hui et ma conviction me rendent
encore plus fort devant ce genre de
témoignage que je ne peux accepter et
devant et je suis prêt à m'exprimer à
parler de ce problème en toute
transparence en toute clarté mais sur
des faits précis passion des allégations
sur des preuves précise pas sur du
cannet râteau ou d où des rumeurs
malheureusement notre monde aujourd'hui
est basée sur la communication
moi j'ai toujours été dans l'action
peut-être qu'il faudrait trouver un
équilibre entre la communication de
l'action aujourd'hui l'action est
pénalisé par ce type de communication
est en tous les cas je ne pense pas
qu'on lutte efficacement contre le
dopage ce pour le connais ici
aujourd'hui je pense qu'au contraire on
favorise en favorisent ce fléau que j'ai
toujours combattu et que je tienne à
préciser encore plus fort aujourd'hui
merci
puisque vous parliez de laurent benazeth
c'est vrai qu'il ait vu devant notre
commission et je crois me souvenir qui
nous a dit qu'il avait la conviction
forte que pendant la coupe du monde 1995
il aurait été entre guillemets traité à
la cortisone
vous étiez entraîneurs et médecins de
l'équipe de france cette époque que
pensez vous de cette affirmation
elle est peut-être déjà peut-être déjà
replacé avant d'aborder le problème
médical déjà replacé dans le contexte
global d'une organisation de coupe du
monde ou du moins de cette coupe du
monde
voir comment fonctionnait à l'époque
très peu de très peu de rassemblements
je crois que l'année de coupe du monde
donc l'année 95
on a eu en tout et pour tout quarante
jours compétition comprise pour préparer
ce groupe donc il faut savoir qu'à
l'époque magie tournoi pour un pour
illustrer mon propos match du tournoi le
samedi on était réunie le mercredi 11
heures pour jouer le samedi
donc c'est une toute autre époque et
effectivement les périodes où on pouvait
se retrouver c'était les périodes de
tournai où les périodes de coupe du
monde où on partait remporter pour
quatre et cinq semaines
d'où pour nous cette opportunité ce
créneau-là d'organiser un travail de
haut niveau puisque on avait la
possibilité de travailler en continuité
sur la durée avec un groupe et quelque
part c'est ce qui nous a permis qui nous
a permis s'ils voulaient d'avoir
certains résultats en tournée argentine
92 afrique du sud 93 nouvelles zones 94
et donc compétitifs pour cette coupe du
monde 95 qui se terminera en demi finale
contre l'afrique du sud pour les zones
que vous savez
donc dans l'organisation l'avait base et
nous effectivement sur un travail assez
intense dans ces périodes là où on
pouvait concentrer les joueurs et à voir
les joueurs à disposition
en continuité j'ai toujours essayé de
développer le secteur de la préparation
physique le secteur du médical j'ai
toujours fait appel à des gens
compétents sur ces domaines là pour
pouvoir encadrer et amener des joueurs à
leur meilleur niveau notamment sur le
plan physique pour pouvoir ensuite
développer les habiletés tactique et
technique dans mon souci dans
l'organisation de notre travail ça a été
de développer toujours cette préparation
ce suivi médical et la préparation
physique qui sont deux éléments
complémentaires de la préparation
tactique sur le plan médical un ballon
j'essaie d'avoir resituer la question
avec la période ce qui se faisait que ça
c'est important pour nous docteur voilà
justement mais ce qui est très important
c'est que comment nous fonctionnions
avec pierre et avec le staff de l'équipe
c'est à dire que on avait à l'époque des
joueurs qui s'entraînent et trois à
quatre fois par semaine pas plus par
rapport à l'époque que nous connaissons
actuellement est en fait il y avait un
très gros retard sur le prendre de la
préparation physique
or il se trouve que personnellement j'ai
attaqué cette préparation physique pour
lequel on a travaillé ensemble mais on
était à cent mille lieues si vous voulez
des préparations biologique et tout ce
que vous voudrez là on avait besoin de
faire courir les joueurs de les muscles
et parce que il était très très très
très en retard pierre tu m'as raid si je
me trompe
il était très en retard comment je
fonctionne et moi sur le plan médical
médical pur bon en matière de rugby il
ya d'abord la bobologie ou même la
traumatologie puisque c'est quand même
pour sakho n'est à 1
voilà il y avait de temps en temps des
petits problèmes de pathologies
médicales moi j'avais dans mon comme
j'ai toujours eu dans mes affaires
médicales dans mon matériel médical
j'avais des produits qui n'étaient pas
dangereux sur le plan de la législation
est dangereux pour l'utilisation et qui
pouvait être accessible qui était dans
ma valise qu'il est qui était accessible
pour moi mais qui aurait pu être
accessible pour d'autres personnes plus
ou moins bien intentionnés et à côté de
ça j'avais ce qui est toujours bon de
voir de médecin
la trousse d'urgence et mettre aux
urgences oui effectivement il peut y
avoir des injections de corticoïdes et
tout ça qui était à part qui ne me
quittait pas qu'ils étaient toujours
dans ma chambre et personne personne au
grand jamais elle n'avait accès à cette
trousse d'urgence c'était si quelqu'un
faisait un oedème de quick ou je ne sais
quoi d'autre ne vraiment urgent et
partant de là dans les produits que
j'utilisais je n'avais jamais jamais de
produits qu'ils pouvaient être dopants
voilà parce que quiconque était sur la
liste
nous sommes bien d'accord je n'en avais
jamais et donc quand ce monsieur dit à
l'insu de mon plein gré parce que
quelques années plus tard j'ai pris les
corticoïdes et je me suis retrouvé dans
une forme d'euphorie qui m'a rappelé
l'euphorie que j'avais pendant la coupe
du monde de 95 quand ce monsieur dit ça
je dissèque c'est la madeleine de proust
cc comment comment peut-on dire marc
bichon à l'insu de mon plein gré et
allez me donner la cortisone
comment peut-on dire ça voilà voilà ma
réponse monsieur le président la
question est at il fait l'objet d'un
traitement à la cortisone ou pas à mon
sens non c'est une réponse à mon sens
faisant poser
nous a dit aussi lorsqu'il est venu à
notre rencontre
un autre demande
je le cite comme ça choses sont claires
l'équipe de france avait un médecin
responsable qui était marc bichon à
manager qui était pierre berbizier
je ne pense pas que ma religion est pris
d sauf de son fait la responsabilité de
mettre en place un protocole médicalisé
sans en référer au manager général est
majeur général pierre berbizier
je ne pense pas qu'il n'ait pas pris
qu'il ait pris la décision sans en
référer au président de la fédération de
l'époque qui était monsieur vers le
passé vous êtes sous serment est ce que
vous démentez ces propos qui a obtenu
monsieur bellaiche complètement ce qui
me concerne complètement ce qui ce qui
me concerne j'ai pu avoir si j'ai pu
avoir des problèmes avec ma fédération
mots si on a toujours été par ces propos
il attaque aussi ma fédération je trouve
ça complètement déplacé autant avec
dernière la passe et on s'est toujours
expliqué franchement je répète je n'ai
pas toujours été d'accord avec lui et
notamment sur la préparation de cette
coupe du monde
parce qu'évidemment j'espérais avoir un
peu plus au temps comme tous les
entraîneurs des équipes nationales qui
souhaite d'avoir un maximum de temps de
préparation qui plus est par rapport à
ce que je vous ai dit précédemment à
savoir que la continuité dans le travail
certains travaillent nous amener à être
compétitifs et nous aurait permis je
pense d'être encore plus compétitif
puisque chez la frustration aujourd'hui
que c'est pas dix centimètres qui nous a
manqués comme on vous l'a vendu les 10
centimes en deux mais ce sont des
kilomètres de préparation ont maîtrisé
un fonctionnement que l'on avait validé
lors des pressions des précédentes
tournées au travers des résultats qu'on
avait acquis sur des nations majeures
qu'on allait rencontrer et donc quelque
part ça remet ça remet en question tous
toute cette organisation mais est ce la
même cause aussi une fédération qui n'a
jamais en tous les cas cette période
avec bernard
passé qui n'a jamais qui n'a jamais
trempé là dedans donc quelque part je
suis profondément blessée par pas ce
genre de de propos effectivement si je
peux me permettre de tuer le président
je devrai donner un élément de réponse
aussi je n'ai jamais obéi à quelle
pression que ce soit et en toute amitié
si dans le passé aussi pierre berbizier
m'avait demandé d'accéder à ce genre de
pratiques
j'aurais présenter illico presto à
l'émission écarté le monde noir
ça au moins le mérite d'être clair d'une
manière plus générale entendu des choses
ont pressé de revenir sur les
principales choses qui ont été évoqués
il nous a affirmé que en matière de
dopage et je le cite
ouvrez les guillemets leurs aiguilles
est exactement dans la même situation
que le cyclisme en affaire festina vous
apercevez je pense le poids d'une telle
affirmation affaire festina était
semble-t-il quand même une affaire
largement commentée et qui a suscité de
nombreuses réactions donc qu'en pensez
vous
pour avoir été un des premiers à
dénoncer dans l'arrivée du
professionnalisme les cadences
infernales et l'arrivée de l'argent ça
m'avait valu à l'époque un certain tollé
simplement le fait de dire attention le
professionnalisme les cadences
infernales l'arrivée de l'argent ce sont
des conditions qui peuvent créer le
dopage c'était au début des années 2000
heureusement que marie george buffet à
l'époque ministre jeunesse et sports on
avait un petit peu sauvé du lynchage
médiatique qui avait été sur ces seuls
propos mais qui voulait simplement et
clairement positionné et me positionner
dans ce dans ce débat là pour
luttez c'était en termes préventif donc
et qui est encore plus aujourd'hui mais
ma position
alors effectivement comparer à l'
affaire festina en ce qui me concerne
j'ai jamais vu dans le monde du rugby
que ce soit un club que ce soit au
niveau fédéral un système organisé
institutionnalisée de dopage donc dans
ce quelqu'un c'est pas donnez moi je
vous interromps si je réponds à la
question je pensais vous posez je vous
la pose
avez vous été témoin direct ou indirect
de pratiques dopantes dans le rugby j'ai
eu pour ma part j'ai été confronté deux
fois avec une fois au niveau de mon club
le racing avec un joueur qui a été
contrôlé au cannabis et je l'étais une
autre fois en italie avec un joueur
aussi sur un produit qu'on dit entre
guillemets festif en préparation de
préparation de coupe du monde ont
procédé à des tests internes pourra
vendre avant de choisir le groupe et on
avait été enfin j'avais sorti ce joueur
qui avait été pris aussi sur sur ce type
de produits voilà pour ma part les deux
fois où j'ai été confronté à des
contrôles positifs sur sur le dopage
tout en étant tout en étant conscient
aujourd'hui est ce que j'avais signalé
en 2000 que on n'est pas à l'abri et que
soit le rugby avec les valeurs du rugby
que l'on prétend que l'on nous vend
aussi pour parfois nous endormir
je crois que je suis lucide là dessus on
l'est pas on n'est pas l'abri on les
confronte et encore plus aujourd'hui
avec le mixage des populations
rugbystique aujourd'hui l'hémisphère sud
vous avez un mouvement permanent ce
qu'on n'avait pas à l'époque que vous
aviez une certaine stabilité
ou on peut effectivement être mieux où
le joueur peut être mis aujourd'hui en
contact avec avec ces méthodes là
pour ma part je n'ai jamais connu hormis
les deux situations que que je vous ai
un que je vous ai cités donc selon vous
ces pratiques n'étaient pas généralisée
ne le sont toujours quoi je dirais je
précise quand on n'est pas l'abri on
n'est pas l'abri d'une automédication
médicamentation aujourd'hui
effectivement
d'ailleurs ça pose tout le problème de
notre de notre formation et je
m'inquiète d'ailleurs pour notre
formation des jeunes qui en ferme qui
enferme dans des ghettos des jeunes qui
a qui ont fait espérer des contrats
mirobolants
aujourd'hui en ce qui nous concerne
rugby on appris le modèle du football
aujourd'hui effectivement des sommes
d'argent assez conséquente que l'on fait
miroiter à des jeunes et qui sont
peut-être prêts à tout avec ces
phénomènes de groupe de regroupement où
ils ont que ça à faire couper du
quotidien où ils sont peut-être prêts à
tout pour décrocher un premier contrat
donc effectivement je crois qu'il faut
être vigilant au niveau de la formation
vigilant aussi bien évidemment au niveau
professionnel je ne suis pas sûr
effectivement que certains ne soient pas
amenés par rapport à la contrainte aussi
du haut niveau a à faire usage parle pas
ça on n'est pas l'abri effectivement
merci
pour rompre la monotonie de ma voix j'ai
passé le relais à mon rapporte a préféré
qu'ils ont bien vouloir continuer jean
jacques lozach bien merci à monsieur le
président monsieur berbizier avant
d'être entraîneur avant d'être
sélectionneur du quinze de france vous
avez été un joueur un joueur de très
haut niveau pendant une dizaine d'années
vous avez été demi de mêlée du quinze de
france est ce que justement comme joueur
pendant cette période là vous avez été
je dirais confrontés à ce problème du
dopage est ce que c'était un sujet que
vous évoquez entre vous sein du club au
sein du quinze de france ou bien est-ce
que c'était quelque chose quitter qui
était passé sous silence qui était
occultée on était loin de ces
préoccupations je crois que voulons
discuter un petit peu avant
d'effectivement ce qui a changé avec
l'arrivée du professionnalisme quand on
voit la longévité aujourd'hui des des
carrés à des joueurs
je suis d'une génération à 30 ans
commence à être vieux parce que le
travail le travail n'était pas le même
n'était pas de qualité
la récupération surtout problème c'est
que je suis d'une génération où à 30 ans
ou en investissant bringue dans le
corner comme on dit et en terme de
récupération on le paye et on le paye et
aux alentours de 100 aujourd'hui avec la
qualité du travail et d'encadrement
parce que je crois aussi qu' il faut il
faut valider la qualité du travail qui
est fait en matière de préparation et
aussi avec la récupération à l'époque et
je les préciser j'étais joueur en équipe
de france mais on travaille elles ont
travaillé lundi
donc ce problème de récupération était
était un gros problème pour son travail
mais ce que m'a fait comprendre un peu
joueur le haut niveau je les ai ensuite
continuer en tant qu'entraîneur je crois
que c'est le travail
moi je suis arrivé au niveau par le par
le travail donc j'ai compris que si pour
arriver au niveau et pour y rester
c'était par le travail j'ai toujours
chez toujours essayer justement d'avoir
cette culture du travail et transmettre
cette culture de travail parce que je
pense que c'est la base indispensable
d'une d'une réussite au plus haut niveau
que ce soit en tant que joueur que ce
soit en tant qu'entraîneur alors un
travail encadré un travail qualifié en
fonction des spécificités bien bien
évidemment c'est pour ça je le répète
que je me suis toujours entouré et
chercher à développer les secteurs de la
préparation physique et de l'encadrement
médical en termes de récupération
notamment qui qui permettait justement
de pouvoir amener le joueur et l'équipe
à maximiser son potentiel
cela a pourtant continué oui continuer
sur cette même préoccupation est ce
qu'un certain moment je regardais dessus
parce que cela a été dit lors d'une
audition précédente vous avez été en
quelque sorte trouble est dubitatif face
à l'évolution morphologique des joueurs
de l'hémisphère sud
oui oui c'est vrai qu'on a on a vu mais
je crois que c'est je crois que l
évolution naturelle de le travail
marc michaud précisé travailler 3 4 à 3
4 entraînements ma paire de joueurs et
ensuite ma paire d'entraîneurs
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui et j'entends une
qualité de travail
aujourd'hui je suis d'une génération
l'utilisé pas la musculation
très peu en effectivement il ya quand
même 7 cette préparation cette
musculation qui est qui est arrivé il ya
aussi l'évolution de naturel aujourd'hui
vous avez à des joueurs
qui a qui dans le profil des groupes que
vous avez la différence mon époque un
joueur comme celle à 85 kg et est
considéré comme un monstre un monstre
physique
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas une trois
quarts ou très peu de trois carats de
haut niveau sont à moins de 100 kg donc
il ya une évolution naturelle est aussi
une évolution des méthodes de travail
la musculation la récupération qui amène
qui amène ces profils
qui plus est vous parliez de
l'hémisphère sud vous avez quand même
une arrivée notamment des joueurs des
îles qui physiquement et pour voilà pour
l'avoir constaté sont quand même des
phénomènes sûr sur le plan sur le plan
physique mais effectivement je me suis
posé parfois la question quand je vois
l'évolution de certains joueurs
je dirais pas en règle générale mais
effectivement il ya eu parfois des des
doute dans mon esprit surtout quand vous
êtes confrontés sur le terrain'' à ce
problème là parce que vous êtes là pour
gagner et que parfois vous dites mais
ces équipes là elles ont un rendement
physique supérieure quand vous comparez
les méthodes de travail
donc effectivement j'ai eu parfois des
doutes ces doutes sont dissipés
aujourd'hui vous avez le sentiment que
ça a été autrefois mais c'est plus qu'un
jour non je crois que je reste assez
vigilant là dessus je suis pas naïf les
doutes mais en même temps je crois je
crois aussi peut être par naïveté je
pense aussi que le joueur de haut niveau
peut être arriver au niveau avec avec
des méthodes des méthodes normal je me
suis toujours battu pour ça donc je
crois ou quand que c'est possible même
si effectivement on peut être on peut
être amené à douter a parfois oui
oui tout à l'heure vous l'avez vous
l'avez rappelé de manière un peu un peu
détourné un peu elliptique
c'est une époque où vous même par un
certain nombre d'expressions public à
saddam de déclarations vous aviez jeter
un petit peu le le pavé dans la mare
jeté un petit peu le trouble bon j'ai
sous les yeux en particulier l'équipe
magazine du 6 janvier 2001 oui vous
disiez le dopage est une réalité dans le
championnat en france on pratique une
politique de l'autruche et c est ce que
ces propos là vous le voulez confirmé
dans le sens dans le sens où regarder
bien j'avais les cadences infernales et
l'arrivée et l'arrivée de l'argent on
pouvait créer ces conditions là c'est
dans ce sens là que que je les dis et je
confirme je confirme ses propos
donc dans le sens où on doit rester on
devait rester vigilants dans
l'encadrement dans l'encadrement et je
dirai ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
dans la formation de nos joueurs de haut
niveau mais là ce moment là où faisait
référence uniquement à l'utilisation
éventuelle de créatine ou d'autres
produits dopants dans le rugby non le
nom je vous dis dans quel contexte
chez évoqué ses propos dans ma dans ce
sens dans ce sens là je le répète mes
chers collègues qui souhaitent
stéphane mazars ouais j'suis désolé de
revenir sur la question précédente mais
c'est vrai que dans dans vos propos
c'était en 2001 effectivement vous étiez
s'était pas tellement des propos qui
visaient à prévenir mais vous étiez
plutôt affirmatif à ce moment là de ce
qui pouvait se passer puisque dans
l'équipe c'était en janvier 2001 vous
disais que le dopage d'une réalité dans
le championnat alors est-ce qu'à
l'époque vos propos ont été travesti
vous disiez d'ailleurs qu'à ce moment là
vous aviez essuyé un peu les foudres du
milieu et que la ministre nous avait je
vous répète dans lequel dans quel sens
j'ai tenu ces propos
je crois qu'il fallait être il fallait
être vigilant et et je crois qu'il faut
rester vigilant oui ces propos
d'ailleurs si vous reprenez est ce qu'il
ya une titre est-ce que vous pensez que
journal comme l'équipe n'aurait pas fait
son titre là dessus quel est le titre
quel est le titre de l'article 6 6 avait
été autrement quel est le titre
l'article
si effectivement en 2001 ouvrant des
comptes donc pour vous préciser le
contexte est ce qu'un journal comme
l'équipe n'aurait pas fait ses gros
titres
vous avez le titre de vous avez le titre
de l'article
il y avait quatre pages effectivement
sur l'évolution c'était dans le cadre de
l'évolution du rugby
donc effectivement ni me poser la
question du dopage mais c'est sur
l'entretien de quatre pages imaginez
l'équipe si j'avais comment l'équipe
n'aurait pas pu fêter son titre là
dessus effectivement il ya deux lignes
et dans le sens que je vous évoque
imaginez est ce que l'équipe ne se
serait permis ou n'aurait pas fait un
titre là dessus si ç'avait été autrement
je suis pas le rédacteur en chef de
l'équipe à son nom mais c'est c'est pour
ça je vous dit en fait que reprendre
effectivement qu'un louis mail était en
tournée propos c'est pour ça que je vous
redonne le contexte c'était là d'entre
eux tiennent de l'équipe de l'équipe
magazine exactement un entretien de
quatre pages qui était basée sur
l'évolution du rugby et abandonné
effectivement il y avait la question
ne me suis pas si vous voulez sorti j'ai
effectivement dans le sens où le dopage
doit être il faut être vigilant avec les
cadences infernales l'arrivée de
l'argent c'est dans ce sens là si
effectivement il y avait autre chose je
vous précise je pense que l'équipe
aurait à aurait sorti un titre là dessus
non c'est ces deux lignes dans un
entretien de quatre pages sur
l'évolution du rugby
effectivement il était normal d'évoquer
le d'évoquer le problème lorsqu'un 2001
aujourd'hui on sait effectivement que
l'argent est là que les canons sont de
plus en plus importante et est ce que la
vigilance est au rendez vous
je me pose la question je suis comme
vous j'ai envie de vous la poser
c'est pour ça que je vous ai donné je
vous ai donné la formation aujourd'hui
notre formation
j'ai des doutes j'ai des doutes sur
je n'ai pas les réponses j'ai essayé
j'ai monté dans le projet du racing
métro une formation effectivement
aujourd'hui on appris on a pris le
modèle du foot
moi je crois que l'originalité la
différence du rugby c'était la dimension
sociale par simplicité par commodité on
a recréé le modèle du foot je le
regrette mais effectivement j'ai été
obligé en tant que responsable de
randonnée de de m'aligner sur ce qui se
fait et aujourd'hui je me pose la
question sur notre formation de haut
niveau et j'ai des craintes j'ai des
doutes comme je pouvais l'avoir en 2001
ça m'a pas empêché d'être concret sur
sur le terrain d'amener des réponses les
miennes qui sont ce qu'elles sont mais
en même temps je me suis toujours posé
des questions un entraîneur ou
l'entraîneur que je suis jeune et j'ai
ré que des incertitudes je n'ai jamais
eu de certitude
je me suis toujours posé plus de
questions que je n'ai roulé de réponse
et je crois que c'est le propre de
l'entraîneur en tous les cas de
l'entraîneur que j'ai été et c'est dans
ce sens là que effectivement je me pose
les mêmes questions aujourd'hui sur
notre formation est ce qu elle forme le
joueur de rugby de dos mais est-ce
qu'elles forment l'homme de demain
je regrette simplement qu'on ait
abandonné notre originalité notre
différence
cette dimension sociale qui a mené le
joueur de rugby a côtoyé le quotidien en
terminant ce qui lui permettait
d'atteindre le haut niveau en tant que
joueur de rugby mais qui lui permettait
de continuer aussi en tant qu'ong on à
choisir notre modèle j'ai fait avec
aussi parce que on est on est obligé
j'ai fait avec mais je suis obligé
aujourd'hui de faire ce constat est ce
que c'est la bonne formation pour nos
joueurs de rugby de demain
si vincent clerc puis oui monsieur le
président à la du fou j'ai j'avais la
même question sur la vigilance sur le
fait que vous disiez en 2001 qu'il
fallait être vigilant est ce que
effectivement vous avez l'impression que
naît de répondre sur sur le fait que
vous d'outils un petit peu qu'on ait été
suffisamment vigilants nous on se pose
des questions si je pense que c'est bien
de se poser les questions et nous ce
qu'on recherche c'est de voir comment on
peut être plus efficace dans la lutte
contre le dopage
donc moi j'ai l'impression à vous
entendre qu'il ya une taupe âge dans le
rugby vous posez des questions vous y
répondez pas tout le temps mais j'ai
cette impression là vous êtes tombé si
j'irais bien quand je suis actif dans
l'action de la bonne action par exemple
le dernier projet aura si effectivement
en matière de préparation physique j'ai
renforcé la préparation physique
j'ai renforcé le secteur médical tous
les produits complémentaires que l'on
peut donner c'est nous qui est donnio
certifié contrôlés par des to be voilà
en termes d'actions mon action ensuite
effectivement mon action est limité par
rapport aux problèmes aux problèmes en
général mais j'ai toujours essayé de
donner des réponses dans mon action j'ai
entendu je vous jure mais pas du tout ça
en question simplement marquer mais
question c'était de se dire est ce que
concrètement par rapport à ce que vous
vivez vous avez vécu au sein d'un club
ou dans leur équipe de france est-ce que
vous pensez que les contrôles sont
suffisants les contrôles internes dire
que les prises de sons les contrôles
réguliers sont ils suffisants pour
s'assurer qu'il n'ya pas effectivement
de joueurs qui à votre insu prennent des
des produits dopants est-ce que c'est
aussi l'équipe de france et quelles
seraient les trois mesures concrètes
pour améliorer la lutte contre le dopage
dans le rugby
est-ce que vous avez trois dispositions
qui vous semblerait devoir être prises
pour améliorer puisque on est tous en
train de chercher cette amélioration
qu'est ce que pour vous il serait utile
de prendre cap disposition de manière
globale je revienne à mon dada la
formation je crois qu'il faut être
vigilant dès dès ce moment là et faire
prendre que son niveau de l'information
au niveau au niveau des pratiques au
niveau je pense alors cédé des petits
détails que je parle de préparation
physique de suivi diététique je pense
que c'est une éducation
avant tout je crois et bienne bien
informé bien informé nos jeunes ça passe
à mon sens par de la formation dans un
premier temps être très strict là dessus
ça passe par une organisation du travail
qui va permettre un équilibre entre la
compétition l'entraînement et la
récupération ce qui n'est pas toujours
le cas et ça que ce soit au niveau de la
formation au niveau de la compétition
des plus grande quand vous voyez
aujourd'hui
l'enchaînement le calendrier
international national est différente
donc je crois que ça passe aussi par une
organisation du travail différente
ça passe aussi par les par les contrôles
donc ça passe par les contrôles en
interne on l'a toujours pratiqué dans
l'est dans les structures où j'étais
j'ai toujours fait en sorte jusqu'à
contrôlée par rapport aux produits
complémentaires que l'on peut donner aux
joueurs
ça passe par un contrôle et ceux qui
notamment ceux qui arrivent de
l'extérieur vous êtes obligé pour pas
prendre liberté de leur demander ce
qu'il faut de contrôler ce qui est ce
qu'ils font et ça passe aussi par après
la prévention ça passe aussi par peur de
la sanction parce que vous ne pourrez
pas éviter les cas les cas particuliers
mais je crois qu'il est important de
revenir un petit peu sur notre formation
mais sur notre éducation par rapport à
ce triptyque compétition
entraînement récupération je pense qu'on
est toujours en décalage on ne respecte
jamais cette cet équilibre le joueur de
haut niveau que ce soit au niveau de la
formation que ce soit au plus haut
niveau est toujours en déséquilibre
merci alain dufaut merci monsieur le
président je vous ai bien écouter tous
les deux depuis le début c'est vrai que
vos parcours sportif professionnel
d'éducateurs plaide pour vous je crois
que six bien six à l'occasion de cette
audition devant une autre commission
vous avez pu rétablir une partie de
vérité votre vérité de thomas m'a
personnellement je m'en félicite
alors c'est vrai comme il aime le dire
mon collègue que le but notre commission
s'ils décident de faire des propositions
concrètes pour améliorer la lutte contre
le dopage est ici au sénat je suis un de
ceux qui se bat contre ce fléau depuis à
peu près 25 ans et dieu sait que nous
avons parcouru un trajet positif avec
des avancées mais bien évidemment le
dopage est toujours en avance et c'est
très très difficile de lutter de manière
très efficace
alors c'est vrai que ce qu'il faut
distinguer aussi dans la prévention
c'est que c'est pas seulement le côté
triste l'atteinte à l'éthique du sport
de paris
c'est aussi l'atteinte à la santé du
sportif
et c'est peut-être un élément qu'on ne
met pas suffisamment en avant atteinte à
la santé qui peut aller jusqu'à la mort
dans certains cas et là je pense qu'il
ya un rôle à jouer par les éducateurs
auprès des jeunes qui est fondamental
est ce que le docteur paul drayson
invite oui merci de me donner la parole
là dessus parce que c'est quelque chose
qui me tient très à coeur
nous sommes très très vigilants il ya
quand même des textes qui ont été
produits en particulier il ya la loi de
février 2004 sur le suivi longitudinal
l'un de nos sportifs avec un certain
nombre de règles ou on a demandé à
chaque fédération de bien faire son
cahier de charges en terme de protection
et de prévention en matière de médical
afin de ne pas mettre nous nos sportifs
nos joueurs de rugby en l'occurrence
mais aussi dans toutes les disciplines
ne pas les mettre en danger
donc il ya un certain nombre de mesures
qui ont été prises au travers de cette
première mouture de la loi de février
2004 et qui ont été un petit peu a
ensuite amélioré par chacune des
fédérations puisque bon c'est sûr que le
la surveillance biologique de rugbyman
n'est pas la surveillance biologique
d'un marathonien où le nageur 1 puisque
les contraintes ne sont pas les mêmes
voilà donc il ya quand même un certain
nombre de choses qui ont été faites mais
je crois effectivement je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous qu'il faut aller
encore beaucoup plus loin 1 tous les
jours tous les jours pour avoir après ma
carrière dans le monde du rugby pourra
continuer avec des clubs professionnels
j'ai téléchargé du de la surveillance du
recrutement de certains joueurs et est
donc être s'enquérir de l'état de santé
de l'individu qui était qui étaient
recrutés et surtout de l'avenir qui lui
était réservée surtout ne pas nous
mettre en danger pour son avenir et et
sa santé personnelle de l'eso futur
voilà et là je rebondis sur ce que vient
de dire pierre berbizier ça ça commence
aussi dès le plus jeune âge voilà tout
toute ma carrière depuis 35 ans
maintenant
j'ai toujours travaillé avec des enfants
et adolescents sportif ce qui est une
grande passion pour moi et je suis très
très vigilant là dessus je travaille
pour ne rien vous cacher je m'occupe du
centre de formation du toulouse football
club actuellement en tant que médecin et
donc je suis très attentif à recrutement
de ces petits joueurs à leurs blessures
on est on est très présent sur compte
et effectivement on va faire je pense
que si on occupe bien le terrain comme
l'a dit pierre tout à l'heure il faut
occuper le terrain c'est de loin la
meilleure des préventions contre le
dopage il faut être présent
je crois que c'est ça la réponse est pas
une et pas uniquement pour les sportifs
de haut niveau la future élite
moi je collabore avec l'agencé nationale
pour l'éducation par le sport
je vois qu'il ya des des projets
magnifiques
je regrette simplement que le sport ne
sont pas plus prises en compte dans
notre éducation jeu parce que ça passe
aussi par l'éducation de base et non pas
par l'éducation de notre seule élite le
sport le sport allie cas à l'école peut
être aussi une solution qui permettrait
l'éducation de notre future élite quelle
que soit la la discipline la spécialité
d'autant plus raison le reste si
commentaires que l'éducation à partir de
l'instant et comme déjà fin d'année qui
sont écoulés donc il vaut peut-être
mieux commencer un peu avant et jean
claude carle oui merci monsieur le
président m'excuse auprès d'eux vous
n'avoir pu écouter la totalité de vos
propos peut-être avez-vous déjà répondu
à la question je vais me poser lors
d'une première audition un médecin
chargé du contrôle des contrôles au
laboratoire de châtenay malabry nous a
dit ça nous a quelque peu surpris que
c'était lé rugby et qui arrivait en tête
des contrôles positifs alors ça bien sûr
il faut pondérer tout ça on a parlé dans
le détail des produits qui disait
qu'elle était ce type de contrôle
mais est ce que cette déclaration vous a
surpris
j'ai vu aujourd'hui je crois dans
l'équipe d'autres chiffres donc je me
méfie toujours des chiffres et surtout
de leur analyse donc
c'est comme les sondages on fait dire ce
que l'on veut aux chiffres sondages donc
bon je préfère retenir effectivement que
ça existe aussi dans le rugby
je crois que ça veut dire se ce problème
là il faut pas le il faut pas leur jeter
dire loulo après quelle est la valeur
des chiffres je ne sais pas le plus
important c'est que ça existe qui année
a déjà qu'on soit déjà présente ça veut
dire que le problème existe donc il faut
traiter le problème il faut être je
reviens il faut être vigilant et être
collaboratif dans les solutions que l'on
va que l'on va donner après peu peu ou
plus je ne sais pas il faut faire
attention aux chiffres mais par contre
la réalité est bien là il faut être
vigilant
merci
docteur felipe contepomi yves qui est
venu pour notre nation qui attire
quelque temps s'est inquiété de la prise
abusive d'un certain nombre de
compléments alimentaires par les joueurs
voir ailleurs mais quand j'ai surtout du
rugby
quel est votre sentiment sur ce sujet
des compléments alimentaires mais je
n'ai jamais été un fanatique de ce genre
de pratiques
je le dis très clairement oui je plaide
entre guillemets non coupable parce que
ça ça ne m'a jamais intéressé j'ai
toujours pensé que par ce qu'avec sur
certains de mes amis on appelle la
préparation cacher c'est à dire bien
bien récupérer bien bien ce bien dormir
une s'alimenter bien s'hydrater
je pense que déjà les ya quand même un
certain nombre d'ingrédients qui sont
suffisants après c'est vrai qu'il a des
sports a trait aux dépenses énergétiques
et ces sports a trait aux dépenses
énergétiques avec beaucoup de
transpiration beaucoup de sudation
peuvent
on peut tout à fait imaginer qu'il y à
des pertes sudorales qu'ils soient très
importants déco soit menée effectivement
à compenser ces pertes mais de là à en
faire quelque chose de systématiser bon
je pense que devant votre commission
vous avez certainement eu des gens qui
font parler de certaines pratiques comme
l'anneau micronutrition des choses comme
ça moi j'avoue que personnellement j'ai
toujours été hostile à ce que quelqu'un
en commençant sa journée président
prenne très j'ai lu le sous prétexte
qu'il fallait courir beaucoup ont nagé
beaucoup je trouve ça un petit peu
aberrant d'autant plus qu'il n'ya pas
entre guillemets de vérité scientifique
derrière tout ça donc c'est parfois
souvent les questions de marketing
julien que dans votre réticence à
l'égard de l'utilisation de ce type de
produits il y avait
conscientes ou inconscientes la prise de
risque pour les sportifs d'être embarqué
dans une affaire de dopage à leur insu
oui / je vous pose oui oui oui oui mais
c'est vrai c'est ce que disait pierre
tout à l'heure il faut effectivement
quand vous êtes confrontés moi je ne
suis plus là mes yeux comme comme pierre
avec ses joueurs de rugby être confronté
à des gens qui bouffent des protéines
des trucs comme ça il faut il faut
s'assurer de ce qu'il ya dedans parce
qu'effectivement par internet vous
trouvez tout aujourd'hui mieux je veux
dire donc on peut arriver à faire
n'importe quoi et donc effectivement oui
il faut être
ça a été un petit peu le problème de la
créatine la créatine et à une époque
était le produit miracle c'était un
produit marketing et puis après on s'est
aperçu que certaines craintes il y avait
des anabolisants donc en concert à bercy
après coup effectivement là c'est c'est
des problèmes que vous récupérez et kiwi
faut être oui faut être vigilant il ya
eu ce phénomène de mode
c'était la créatine donc alors dans
quelle proportion ne savait pas on était
un petit peu et je crois que laisser le
joueur dans l'incertitude est dans le
c'est ça je crois qu'au niveau de
l'information et au niveau de la
déformation aussi par rapport à ce genre
de pratique qu'il faut qu'il faut être
qu'il faut de vigilants mais on a été
confronté à ce problème là oui je vais
arriver
votre dernière intervention m'amène à
vous poser une question complémentaire
ce que vous venez de nous dire ça veut
dire que vous avez vu pendant carrière
de joueur vous dirai où pendant votre
carrière d'entraîneur qui n'est pas
terminée vous avez connu ces problèmes
je vous ai parlé la créatine mais vous
avez donc certaine manière rencontrer le
dopage c'est pas du tout j'ai rencontré
le problème de la créatine je vais pas
vous le donc effectivement on a contrôlé
on les dosages les dons qu'il a fallu
qu'il a fallu contrôler donc si vous
voulez à a et on a saoulé j'ai toujours
demandé à ce qu'on sorte de 2 ces
produits là mais vous aviez des joueurs
qui avaient qui avait à ces pratiques là
donc et la créatine n'a jamais on n'a
jamais a donc il faut être il faut être
vigilant
bien évidemment jean pierre chauveau oui
merci juste une petite question et je
crois que mon collègue me dit que vous
ne sentez pas aller tout à l'heure en ce
qui concerne les écoles de rugby les
jeunes
est ce que le suivi médical est vraiment
très poussées ou alors par un certain
niveau je parle par annie des
professionnels mais les jeunes désespoir
définitive est ce qu'il ya vraiment un
suivi médical sérieux quoi et qui leur
montre un petit peu tous les dangers qui
ne peut y avoir à prendre des produits
prohibés
c'est je ne sais sincèrement aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas un très
très très au fait un petit peu de haut
niveau des écoles de rugby
donc je côtoie sur certaines certaines
tours l'aude
j'ai envie de dire que c'est je le
mettrais dans le problème d'éducation je
crois que d'aider l'école de rugby il
faut être
il faut être vigilant c'est un
encadrement de qualité parfois
effectivement cet encadrement et
notamment l'environnement aussi autour
du terrain où est ce que je déplore
pour faire des tournois de temps en
temps c'est la pression qui peut y avoir
autour du terrain cet environnement
d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu la
caractéristique aussi avec le haut
niveau
je crois que le pouvoir les plus sur le
terrain il est autour du terrain cet
environnement que ce soit au niveau des
tournois de jeux de quand vous voyez les
ce qui se passe autour des terrains que
ce soit l'environnement aujourd'hui du
rugbyman professionnel je veux dire que
le vrai danger est là il n'ya pas et il
y à des environnements je dirais à
négatif qui qui amène à des
comportements et des attitudes
dangereuses et aujourd'hui j'ai bien
peur que cet environnement est pris est
pris le dessus donc peut être regarder
aussi des solutions sur l'environnement
du joueur de rugby
que ce soit à l'école de ryes lui que ce
soit ont plu au plus haut niveau
merci
que pensez-vous l'un et l'autre de la
géolocalisation c'est un des éléments
qui a été souvent évoqué devant notre
commission certains étaient favorables
la géolocalisation d'autres totalement
hostile j'ai personnes selon lui trop de
monde et vous qu'en pensez vous
pratiquement s'est fraîchement les
chiens quoi pour celui qui aime ça
changera rapide et claire comment sont
une réponse rapide et claire non mais
c'est vrai il ya un intérêt à mes seins
mais effectivement je sais qu'il fallait
tenir
il fallait tenir un calendrier deux mois
va cesser de deux mois donc donc et et
après effectivement pour tenir ce
calendrier donc je sais que pratiquement
c'est très très difficile à gérer
je pense que l'idée je pense que l'idée
bonne qu'on puisse savoir ce que fait ce
que fait le joueur ce que fait d'athlète
je pense que c'est une bonne chose
est-ce que pratiquement on peut
améliorer à le système donc parce
qu'après effectivement c'est très très
difficile est pour et pour l'athlète ou
pour le joueur qui se sent un petit peu
coupable un petit peu regardez il ya ce
sentiment de culpabilité qui est inquiet
peut-être difficile à vivre et qui
pratiquement les difficiles à gérer
également
et que pensez-vous des contrôles
inopinés
alors là je me permets de répondre
voilà j'ai été le premier en france sur
ordre du ministère des sports à faire un
contrôle inopiné au cra de toulouse
voilà c'était dans les années 80 et
quelques mois je pense que c'est une
très bonne chose
voilà c'est une très bonne chose c'est
une très bonne chose je pense que comme
la géolocalisation c'est ça peut être
une excellente chose parce que c'est pas
au moment des compétitions avec ile de
france on a été contrôlé plein de fois
on a été ont été contrôlés à tous les
matchs on était contrôlé avant de partir
en afrique du sud ont été contrôlés car
dès le jour même de notre arrivée en
afrique du sud je dire on a été contrôlé
plein plein plein de fois ceux qui
adorent étaient souvent très très
pénibles quand on avait un joueur qui
pis est pas parce qu'à l'époque on
faisait pas de prise de sang c'est
uniquement sur les urines et mais
effectivement que ce soit la
géolocalisation que soient les contrôles
inopinés moi je pense que c'est c'est la
base c'est en veut si on veut arriver
dans le côté répressif si vous voulez si
on peut si on veut arriver à quelque
chose c'est comme ça qu'il faut procéder
oui puisque sur les compétitions
le rapporteur vous posez les deux
dernières questions parce que on ne
s'ennuie pas avec vous aimez le temps
passe bien je je reviens quand même sur
l'intervention de laurent bénézech bon
dd compris vous partirez pas en vacances
ensemble
en tout cas pas cette année mais à un
certain moment dans son audition il dit
mon intention est de pousser un cri
d'alarmé concernant les hormones de
croissance d'autant plus qu'elles sont
difficiles à détecter
est ce que vous croyez que ce cri
d'alarmé ce que vous pensez qu'il est
justifié dans dans le rugby
bah oui c'est sûr qu'il faut il céda
même façon que pour pour les
anabolisants l'hormone de croissance
c'est le stade avoir mon coin donc oui
effectivement il a raison c'est sa
laisse et c'est là la fameuse
reichel qui qui fait qu' on va de plus
en plus loin dans un appartement quelque
chose est détectée on essaye d'aller
plus loin que ce soit pas détecté mais
c'est pas que c'est pas que dans le
rugby c'est cesser dans tout le sport
oui bien sûr là il a raison à condition
est ce qu'il est ce qu'il a est-ce qui
vous a donné des cas concret je crois
que c'est très intéressant effectivement
d'aborder le problème est précisément de
de donner des cas concret donc ça aurait
été intéressant effectivement je crois
que ce problème là il faut pas il faut
pas l'occulter
mais effectivement avoir des cas
concrets qui permettent effectivement de
faire avancer
oui alors pour ces questions pour servir
donc modestement nous essayons de poser
les bonnes questions mais en accorde
également une grande importance
un grand intérêt aux preuves matérielles
alors de docteur aujourd'hui vous de
vous poser la question suivante est-ce
que vous avez conservé des fiches
médicales des joueurs permettant par
exemple de montrer qu'aucun d'entre eux
n'ait été soigné à la cortisone
non non parce que sa date je m'en parle
de 95 oui mais oui bien sûr ça date de
18 ans et mes dossiers depuis j'ai
arrêté mon activité aux crêtes je
conserver les dossiers au club de
toulouse et quand j'ai arrêté mon
activité en 2004
ben j'ai fait le vide qui croire quoi
c'est à dire mais sur toujours en
fonction de la règle du déroulement t de
cette commission
vous avez maintenant ça minutes à vous
partager ou au seul choisirait si ces
six militants vous en voudra pas pour
conclure ce que vous aviez à nous dire
sur
problème de la lutte contre le dopage
messieurs je vous en prie je veux bien
commencé sur sur quelques minutes
simplement dire comme vous l'avez déjà
entendu que j'ai été un acteur de cette
lutte antidopage que je continue à
l'être mais de façon beaucoup plus
modeste et que je crois ma conclusion
c'est surtout que je crois beaucoup
ce qu'il a été dit tout à l'heure c'est
à dire à l'occupation nul terrain par
nous membres du corps médical c'est à
dire l'encadrement médical de tous nos
sportifs et que ça commence
effectivement depuis le plus jeune âge
où malheureusement les choses sont
balbutiante pour des questions de moyens
c'est à dire comment on met souvent tous
les moyens sur les sur les équipes
professionnelles et genre de haut niveau
et on l'aimé beaucoup moins pendant
notre ministère des sports grâce aux
structures comme comme le creps de
toulouse comme l'institut national des
sports
là y avait quand même il ya quand même
des bases de travail en terme médical
qui font que cet entourage est fait et
je pense que c'est un entourant et un
accompagnant nounou sportif
quand on se prémunit contre les contre
les risques de ne pas ch tis berbizier
pour savoir où vous auriez aimé com vous
interroge sur autre chose
enfin sur autre chose dans le cadre
version 2 non simplement vous vous
remercier à nouveau de nous avoir un
reçu de d'avoir pu s'exprimer en tout en
toute liberté
donc je pense les changes positifs en
tous les cas sachez que moi je n'avais
besoin mais j'en avais envie
par rapport à certains principes et
certains et certaines convictions liés à
ce problème là auquel j'ai toujours
répondu dans mon action
plutôt pour lutter contre contre ça je
continuerai à le faire par mon
expression sur le terrain ou en dehors
du terrain mais je crois qu'il est un il
est évident que si on ne le fait pas de
la base de l'éducation au plus haut
niveau
tous les efforts qu'on pourra faire
seront très vite réduit à néant
donc je crois que dans le travail que
vous faites c'est l'envié de vous
remercier et de bien précise
effectivement que ce problème n'est pas
la faire que d'une seule catégorie le
sport de le sport de haut niveau
je pense que tous les sportifs sont
doivent être très vite éduquer à ce
problème là et c'est par l'éducation
qu'on pourra lutter le mieux à ce à ce
fléau
merci en tous les cas de nous avoir
reçus et de la permis de vous exprimer
s'ils avouent être venu nous rencontrer
n'ont pas fait beaucoup de d'exception
d'état demande qui avait été faite mais
je pensais que vous concernant il
fallait que vous puissiez vous exprimer
si vous avez le sentiment de pouvoir le
faire c'était vers l asie
merci messieurs
voilà pour l'audition de pierre
berbizier l'ancien entraîneur de
l'équipe de france de rugby ainsi que
celle de l'ancien médecin de cette
équipe marc bichon
vous pourrez la revoir évidemment à tout
instant sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée à vous sur notre
chaîne